读书的时候一定不要冲头读到那个学习的校律特别差
你肯定有这样一个经历啊
就是你很努力也很认真
然后开会书然后上班花的球
而且既然旁边秘密忘
还记得各种各样的笔记
然后你有花了很多时间
可是呢过了一段时间以后
你突然发现这些知识小忘了
就算你记住了以后
你也不知道该怎么用
这个就像我们在那个
就你每个东西都会学
就像那个沙廷里上
你记得换入啊你知道吗知道
但是因为你没有用我
他那个地气不杂识
然后你的知识呢
是建立在沙廷上
就不外面看
这些有结构的
可是一段用的时候
他就会帮他
我把他冲着为豆腐炸冰层
我给大家介绍一套非常有用的方法
就是我一直在身上
我自己横化了很多的领域
就是很难很快进入一个领域
为什么呢
就是我有一套方法
叫做早动三步法
什么叫早动方三步法呢
给大家解释一下
首先第一幕就是定位
就像你有一面强
然后这个强上面是轰轰如夜的
对吧
然后你就像我在这个强上
哪个位置
我可能是要挂着轰条
可能是要挂个化
我在什么位置挂这个轰条挂这个化
我给你
学东西一定要学最少
起碧倍的知识
因为这个现在的其实太多了
你学那么多没有用
我没有不是用盘
对吧
我们通常说后来往啊
通过AI啊
就很容易的要用
就不要学那么多知识
这家家对付的知识
那那说我不知道最少
给你这个知识是什么
那我告诉你个方法
就是你随便到一本书
当然最好是好说
找到这本书以后的话呢
就看着它木入
大家看一下看那个木入里边
哪一块你感兴趣
你就看了一块
不是不要从头到里看
就是三
这个地方感兴趣
我就看了一块
比如说像这些嘛
这件有人
我就胡说到这本书
我要从头到里毛
这不是
你就三
你木入一单位
来
我看到其中一张
叫你自己就可以是一样公司
我对这个感兴趣对吧
我看了以后
自己能不能开家公司的
OK
因为我就看这个
这个叫丁文
第二步叫什么呢
叫早动
早动在这个墙呢
我不要早就动了
这个很关键
把书本和上推荐看
这个的恨意绝是什么
就是不是先学
再去考试
而是先考试
然后再学
这份
我自己有这家公司
怎么认识
什么产品
是我的时间还是我的记忆呢
我的用过是谁
这个产品卖着谁呀
是吧
然后刻在价多草
大概有多少用过
富争隔是什么呀
你要去想你要去思考
你很去说
这我不会怎么办呀
我不会我只能看菜呀
叫我的就是菜
为什么
因为这个时候
那大头开始喜欢模式了
以前是天下是个
啊
忘了能天
现在你变成了雷达事了
就是
我要干什么
然后有这个开始搜索
这个时候你的学习的状态
是主动时的啊
这种学校我非常好
另外一个很好的生同学校
什么叫生同学校
九立的
各位
如果你去
如果你去你是健身房
然后在健身房里边的话
然后你平时都是
黑情股是吧
然后净股是妈妈之后
你每次去打净四十五棒
没有效果
然后最好的棒儿
你的是从
是举五十五棒
就是批过原来的能力高五棒
高五棒的就是叫
当年要是一百棒
就很累很成了
但是呢
我说女帮
那这个时候就会有秦围的思列
然后这个秦围的思列长好的时候
你这个秦围的长分
所以最恰到好处的就是什么呢
就是批我能力全稍微超出一点点
那么你去学一个知识
然后有一个知识进入
这就是稍微强出一点点
这第二个名字的遭动
这三个问题怎么到入定
哎这个特别棒了
因为这时候你也有好秦学口来
做短这边的写文章能够知道
就写文章要好秦学口
什么样好秦学口
我有想法来我有东西了
我有哪些问题了
这个时候我拿开原署
然后我看我一个一个的剑法
你是代表问题
代表后期一学习的
这个知识特别大事了
如果你加油孩子
我给你的所建议
就是给交孩子的方法
不是你给他讲这个知识
而是秦围到秦
最好的他现有的知识和沙测讲的知识中线
你出一个问题
然后他自己想办法解决
你也不需要去解答他
第二天上课的时候
你会发现他的学习效率特别高
因为他的学习的时候
是代表问题学习的
所以各位这是一套非常有用的方法
首先是定位
然后是早动
然后是入定
然后他便利用豆腐达的工程
要有用多因为你学的东西
马上你是用标的
而且你是学习的用的
对吧
好
我得到不行
一定要动入这行事
所以各位
今天晚上就找一本数
然后找到其中一个感兴福的不用停
然后把收盒上想一想
才要讲什么
他自己的那种大概制的
然后带到后期
然后开这个内容
然后一点
一点去对用
所以各位一定要去过
学习不是可以啊
学习是
联合